answer the internet with colin quinn
[Music]
uh who's the number one celebrity will
do dead or alive whose birthday party
you would want to attend
um then celebrity dinner live was
birthday party i would want to attend
um well you know
i think you heard my famous robert de
niro birthday party story right
that's the number one one to remind the
audience
i did barbie de niro's birthday party
his 60th birthday party
and i bombed so badly i not only ruined
his birthday
ten years later him and his wife were
outside the cellar
jim norton goes hey remember when
collins is your birthday party and both
of their faces
darken with hate
what what do you remember like was there
like a specific joke or a moment that
you were like oh
[Laughter]
i remember the entire blow my blood i
remember
calling me and saying hey like you do
this birthday party
just do your general impression for two
minutes and i remember me like ralph
cranby going
i'll do better than that
i remember the waiters faces when i got
there like
envyus like i tried to be an actor and
this guy's making living in showbiz i
remember the way his face is when i left
disgusted was it really that bad like i
can understand the impression maybe but
like at this point you're a professional
comedian like
i i've told the story but my suit
was drenched my suit
not my shirt
[Laughter]
all right so now bob de niro i didn't
sweat on stage
[Laughter]
monumental i don't think i've ever seen
a wetsuit
when you get the pit stains in the
jacket it's special man that is special
it was it was so that's the birthday
party i would definitely would not
attend
you know what i mean obviously you don't
want to ever bomb but now looking back
on it isn't it almost better to have
that story that you bombed so colossally
yeah yeah absolutely i'd rather have
killed
and gotten in forever with scorsese one
of those guys
but given the choice between mediocre
and that i'll take the ball bob
every time if you were kidnapped what tv
cast would you want to come save you
if i was kidnapped tv does that have to
be a show
now or no no no whatever you want i mean
i would say you know this is one of
those questions today
i mean obviously every guy let's just
take this question and say
1998. okay right so the answer to the
question
would be like something sexual with
whatever
know baywatch or whatever yeah yeah so
now
you can't say that even though that's we
want to save you of course
yeah now so what are you gonna say
the the answer would be like oh i'd like
it to be
you know the sopranos well that sounds
sort of like weird like
what you need other guys to say so this
is what i'm talking about
there's got to be a place between toxic
masculinity
and uh you know being a little
you know a wilting flower waiting for a
big [ __ ] to save you from you know
yeah let us know when you find that
middle ground i i'd ask for the queer
eye for the straight guy i want those
guys to come save
what would you do if you only had 30
minutes to live
for only 30 minutes to live that's a
short time
not a lot to get done i couldn't even
take a [ __ ] in 30 minutes
well all right what if i what if i gave
you 24 hours if i had 30 minutes to live
i would
i would buy a pack of cigarettes and
smoke like 12 of them
just let them rip have you have you do
you still smoke
no i've been smoking 20 something years
but i mean i would miss it every day
yeah just
like colin what are you doing i'm almost
about to die dude i'm on number [ __ ]
nine
walmart those just
they they go down like glass man i don't
know those are [ __ ] tough
this season sports is looking a little
bit different but the bat blue light is
here to make sure that fans hashtag gear
up to enjoy their favorite game
ati's gonna look a little bit different
too most of our favorite guests they're
gonna be at home
but one way to feel better about that
get yourself a little that blue light
feel like home yourself
today's featured question featuring
colin quinn brought to you by lebaplue
what's the most embarrassing way to die
within the confines of your average day
so a normal day in colin quinn's life
what's the worst way you could die
well i almost died a very embarrassing
death
i was driving when i lived in l.a i was
driving that low maybe i was visiting
one time
but anyway i was driving and i had a big
gulp one thing i love about the vanello
i got a big gulp i just have a truck
a nice big gulp and then you know
pretzels or whatever
so this day wait a minute you're driving
like a pickup truck or whatever
with a [ __ ] big gulp yes okay
i did not picture that but all right so
i'm driving but this day i made a fatal
error
nearly fatal i bought a box of triscuits
so i finished my big up i didn't realize
i was done with it
so i kept eating triscuits and
i started to choke to death on the
tricks brisket
and i was like and i was driving i'm
saying and i was thinking in my head oh
no
i'm gonna die of choking biscuits
out of all the out of all the snacks too
like you told me you died choking on
pretzels or potato chips but if you die
choking on a trisky you're a [ __ ]
looking and i've got like a miley cyrus
tape
[Laughter]
are you smarter than christopher
columbus
today with your knowledge in the modern
world are you smarter than
any of the greatest like renaissance
minds from you know the 1300s
um absolutely not no
i'm with you yeah you might have more
knowledge of things that exist but
nobody's smarter than these people yeah
but you also think about like
you know there are certain things that
they believe to be true which just were
not that you do yeah you know
you even just you knowing certain things
would make you technically smarter than
him now
well but what we're going to find out
that someday
some idiot 200 years from now be smarter
than us yeah
i think about that what do you what do
you think today is the
you know there was a time where the
whole world believed that the sun
revolved around us
right what do you what do you think that
we're going to learn 200 years from now
that's like can you believe those idiots
in the year 2020 believed
yeah that's a good question um yeah i
mean like uh well probably
alien life yeah yeah you believe in it
yeah you think
do you think they've been here at all
what's that you think aliens have been
here at all
well they keep trying to say they have
been now right yeah that latest report
was pretty [ __ ] crazy
i know and it's like it's just strange
if they if they if they haven't been
they went to a lot of trouble
to put something like that down for what
reason you know yeah yeah it seems like
going out of your way for a little bit
if i gave you a billion dollars right
now but you're never allowed to leave
the state of ohio
would you take it yes yeah yes
they these guys fight me on it it
actually used to be something like a
trillion dollars and we had to scale it
down
they all say they wouldn't take it i
would take a billion dollars and you
could put me in like a single house for
the rest of my life
dude why don't we do the billion dollars
in cleveland i don't know whatever you
want
columbus cincinnati
some of cleveland is cool
[Laughter]
i said with that kind of money you can
bring whatever you need to you
look at chappelle he hasn't left he
hasn't have a billion dollars he hasn't
left
ohio for you know he's got everybody
flying it to visit him yeah
right right you got that money you can
bring it home it doesn't matter where
you are you know so you never go to the
beach again
no you don't strike me as a beach guy
come on
if you if the purge happened uh would
you participate and what what crime
would you commit first
um i would probably you know it used to
be a longer list i'd be sure
but i totally committed murder
i love that to the mature dancer they go
[ __ ] kill them
what people it used to be a purge within
a bird
couple of select people that i probably
i mean either kill or badly wound
like all right give me who's the number
one target i really can't
give me a hint what does his name rhyme
with
all right man well